al norte de kiev en la policía de
Ucrania cree tener localizado al autor
del robo de un mural de banxie en la
ciudad el 2 de diciembre arrancaron de
una de las paredes la obra de arte de
una mujer con una máscara anti gas y
sosteniendo un extintor algo considerado
como un símbolo de la resistencia por
los ucranianos
nos pusimos muy contentos cuando
pintaron el mural aquí para nosotros
este robo es doloroso porque vivimos acá
después de la desocupación volvimos a
casa y ahora hay un agujero es como que
falta algo
ahora con al menos 8 detenidos hasta el
momento el supuesto autor intelectual ha
recibido una notificación para acudir
ante la justicia y podría enfrentar
hasta 12 años de prisión el mural Era
uno de los siete que van si pintó por
todo el país desde la invasión de Rusia
en febrero y está valorado en 243 mil
dólares por suerte la policía consiguió
recuperar la obra casi de inmediato y
asegura se encuentra en buen estado en
las afueras de que no es una ciudad
cualquiera tiene una importante base
militar ucraniana una de las primeras
que cayó durante la invasión y que
estuvo 35 días bajo el control ruso